e aí estava tudo bem com vocês estão
aqui na presença do chefe de aliás logo
estamos aqui pra gravar um super vídeo
muito pedido por vocês então já que
vocês pediram muito já que você escuta
muito meus vídeos então já vai
explicando não gostei que o vídeo vai
ser bom você viu aqui jamaicano gostei é
que vai ser [ __ ] exato ou não o que são
hoje as piauienses muita gente confunde
esse negócio de você falar errado com a
cultura do lugar você conhece você vai
para um lugar e tem muita gente falando
não era diferente para consultar
diferentes você não vai continuar aqui é
tipo um deles se socializar com as
pessoas vão começar a falar com essa vai
mediar e resulta que a ge é tipo nem
quem sabe aqui da saúde rosa é para dona
de são paulo a mostra importa portanto
este ano tinha de dar ciência à absorção
ao passador de energia em pista é uma
forma de se socializar obrigado meu é da
cultura de cada lugar se você for pro
nordeste se você passar dois meses três
meses não deixa você vai começar a falar
que meu pessoal nordeste e ainda tem que
no nordeste logicamente / estado e eu
tenho as idéias de cada estado então
quando você for para usar e do pessoal
já fala de um jeito a um selo que eles o
que havia de capa fala errado ela estava
não está falando errado está falando
como a cultura do lugar dele lei então
vamos a primeira gira rola aí
uma das milhões que ele quer pensa em
uma pessoa fala pensa é como se eu
tivesse tentado aumentar a história por
exemplo eu faço cara eu vi uma matéria
de capa muito forte jô é o mais indicado
é muito forte aqui no nordeste o centro
fosse aumentar já que é dizer sim carro
a europa bater de carro uma batina pinça
entendeu o fato de uma batida ou se
imagina a partir de agora não só assina
pai joão batista pinto na bateria se
imaginou carreta em campo em um avião
caiu bate também vejo meta feita na pr
ou colocar uma mulher bonita é muito
bonita a mais nova não deixa de aumentar
essa razão em muita penso na minha
família era tão difícil ela me jazz por
dia bbl press
[Música]
segundo o g1
no nordeste é surra mo honrada luta que
tenha apelo à paz e amor
mais um macho é aquele cachorro que eu
tenho lá no quintal
pode ser mas nesse caso que não é nesse
caso machuque
é como a gente chama os homens da região
só que machos se usa no ceará mas saiu
de lá na perna que ele não pode ter
cabeça com essa caixa d'água com a mãe
ela viu a ver na pedra que temos feito
para chegarmos num caminho de milão josé
laelson macho maqueta usa tanto eu acho
que a minoria o saque macho última noite
então macho lá no ceará a 12 no acre
piauí e em algumas cidades do nordeste
também aí está uma cena que eu moro em
todas as rodas de ir de férias e me
adora ver
medo eu quero ver tony medonha é quase
na mesma
na mesma linha do ps tem é como se fosse
com você aumentar
não é como se fosse uma posição aumentar
já o que vai ser diferente
qualquer ou queda aberta onde rolou para
direita o francês com uma baita jogador
francês que conhecia porque tinha pouco
a linha matola e vai rolar baitullah e
taduzinho seria verdade então você fala
baitolagem se basicamente um dia da
raiva ou ele vai rolar e atrás
então é isso aí como eu sempre faço
fazer uma história que com todas as
vezes que eu falei este vídeo não é as
pessoas que assistem o canal que tudo o
que vocês acham que eu não gostei hoje a
parma do dou eu assisti uma luta onde
assistiu à luta agora pensa em uma peia
waddle e nunca tomo mais penso apenas
ontem o pmdb eu quero começar a aplicar
que vai rolar de homem de ferro academy
máquina empenho no perth
yudi na vila parece k amor parece um
letreiro em
[Música]
meu perfil eu pergunto se não fosse
assim não é fácil não é o meu perfil
então essa galera se você gostou e se já
sabe que tem que fazer é brincar com
você é muito importante também porque na
atual província uma vez muita gente tem
notícia de que meu terceiro set e isso é
muito bom para quem faz o futebol é
saber quem é que gosta de nosso trabalho
foi criado então muito obrigado a não
ser que tá certo que não gostei
você tá sempre compartilhando está
sempre comentam eu quero você comente
aqui em baixo um giro que tem na
sociedade e na sociedade
ele aguenta aí eu vou ler aquelas que
mais estranhou a eleger aí mostrando as
lutas beleza e terminou só tem olhos
para não perder o vídeo é só explicar
inscrevi se que todo mês - mas sabe sair
aqui no twitter e está no facebook tudo
todos os meios sociais não olha só pai
na descrição do vídeo não quiser então é
isso aí há um muito obrigado por você
está assistindo esse vídeo que até o
final você é muito show e é
[Música]